foreign
[Music]
really takes us backwards on President
Biden's climate commitments these types
of emissions are ones that we cannot
afford if we're going to avoid the worst
in climate change
[Music]
the willow project is meant to go on for
30 years so it locks in these carbon
emissions which we can't afford today
well into the future and as a result
there's just no room in the carbon
budget for these types of Mega projects
[Music]
thank you
the people who live in the community
closest to this development depend on
these resources for their traditional
subsistence way of life and the
government acknowledges that this
infrastructure will have a really heavy
negative effect on those practices
those are positive steps but they do not
offset this major negative carbon bond
that is being exploded right in the
midst of that area
[Music]